on today's show we talked to a wonderful
young mom
who has an abusive past and she wants to
make sure
the cycle stops with her we also talk to
a
mom who's expecting a baby and the dad
doesn't know she's still pregnant
and we talked to a dad of a 17 year old
girl
who he adopted when she was seven and
they no longer
speak how can he lean back in be
vulnerable
and reconnect stay tuned
hey what is up i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone show
a show for you by you about you
we're talking about your life your
relationships your kids your neighbors
the holidays figuring out what 2021 is
going to look like for you
what you can control what you can't want
to help you rethink re-examine and
reconsider
every part of your life how you talk to
yourself how you talk to those people
that you
love how you talk to those people that
you hate how you interact with
people that you kind of like but they
drive you crazy how to
boldly take the next crooked wobbly step
towards finding love again towards being
a person of integrity towards dealing
with loss towards
all of it we're going to talk about
about divorce we're going to talk about
getting back together we're going to
talk about dating we're going to talk
about
all of it so i'm so glad that you're
here
i'm so glad that you've decided i don't
want to be alone anymore i
just want someone to walk alongside me
i'm here and there
are i was going to say millions there's
at least dozens of other people
listening to this podcast right
all over my mom's house and her
immediate friend group right
there the crew is still listening to
this thing so whatever's going on in
your heart
or your home or your head i'm here to
stand with you give me a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693
or you can go to johndaloni.com show
fill out the form
it goes to kelly and her exciting band
of good folks
and then she will see about getting you
on the show
so i want to get to something positive
here in 2021
we're gonna start the year off we're
what a week or two in
i'm gonna start with some positivity
this notice from tory parker
tori parker writes hey dr john i'm
writing to send a shout out your way
i'm the oldest daughter of a very
dysfunctional marriage
that ended in a rocky and nasty divorce
a few years ago
i made the decision to not live with
either of my parents and try to avoid as
at as much dysfunction as possible
i didn't know where to go and in comes
mama stacy
i met her second hand or third hand her
daughter made a little comment about how
cool it'll be if i live with them so i
followed up on that little comment
and nearly two years ago this beautiful
family told me that i could choose any
one of their extra bedrooms in the house
and stay
free of charge they accepted me and made
me part of their family
early on mama stacy kept asking me what
i wanted from the grocery store she knew
i wasn't eating
and i wasn't eating because i didn't
have any money to pay for food
when i refused to ask her for things
from the store she started keeping an
eye out for things i bought for myself
and she started restocking it for the
first time in my life
i can say that i've lived in a
functional though not perfect
family system these folks accepted me
wholeheartedly and loved me generously
and unconditionally mama stacy
and mama stacy family i don't know who
you are i don't know where you're from
i don't even know where this calls where
this letter comes from
but mama stacy out there tori parker
wants to tell you
thank you for filling a gap for stepping
in
and saying you're welcome to stay at our
home you're welcome at our table
and even when she didn't have the words
to speak for herself when tory
didn't even know what to ask for didn't
have the courage
to ask for the right things you kept an
eye out
you were generous you were quiet and you
took care of somebody
if everybody in the world acted like
mama stacy
we'd be problem free kellyanne james
we'd be problem free that's probably not
true but it's fun to say those things
out loud right
all right let's go straight to the
phones today let's go to tiffany
in minot north dakota is it monot
let's see here tiffany how are we doing
hi
i'm good so is it is it monot
might not mind excellent all right minot
north dakota so how in the world are you
i'm good i'm grateful to get to talk to
you and i'm just looking for some guides
all right bring it on how can i help all
right so i'd like to know how to get out
of autopilot and really connect
with my two girls i was brought up in an
abusive environment
so my examples were rather toxic but my
expectations for myself are kind of
romanticized
i know what lack of parental connection
has caused in my adulthood for me
and i just don't want that for my girls
can i tell you you're a rock star you're
super noble and i'm proud of you
thank you and i want to ask you your
first question is this
what about your what you envision for
your daughters
is a fantasy why do you say they're
unrealistic
um i wouldn't say they're unrealistic
but they're kind of
i just figured things would be easier
you know before parenthood
you're always told oh you're gonna make
such a good mom you're gonna do
amazing things they just don't tell you
how hard it is right
no right suckers they all lie to us
i'm the same boat right so tell me about
your childhood
um well i grew up in a
physically emotionally abusive home
mostly my late father my mom
took on more of a father figure when he
passed and
just you know went to work and she you
know knocked it out she's an amazing
woman
she just really didn't have that time to
you know foster
a healthy emotional connection with us
kids
so i really don't know how to
to do that for my girls did you grieve
your dad's
passing um
i don't know that i have fully i mean i
was a teenager
so it was kind of uh just getting
through my teenage years
you know and and my environment was kind
of survival for the most part
okay did you go to a funeral
i did but i didn't view him
i i just felt like i couldn't at the
time
so this is all related okay
but i want you to
when you have some time and i want you
to make an afternoon of it by yourself
okay are you married now i am
okay so i want you to ask your husband
for the afternoon off from the kids
okay and i want you to go somewhere by
yourself
and i want you to write your dad a
letter
and i want you to let him know
that you as a as a mom of two young kids
how you're doing
i want you to let him know how he hurts
you
and that he's not able to hurt you
anymore and then i want you to let him
know
who you are becoming out of that pain
okay
and that will probably be the hardest
letter you've ever had to write
and the hardest season the hardest six
hour block of your life
outside of the actual abuse itself
but here's what i need you to do i need
you to let him
go i need you to unhook him from
the mom you are trying to become the mom
that you already are let's be let's be
honest you're doing a way better job
than you even think you are but i want
you to unhook him and completely
disentangle yourself from that guy okay
okay and then when it comes to setting
up
new new tools new
behaviors new things that you can do to
connect with your kids how old are your
children
they're four and five okay so tell me
about them are they awesome
they're super wonderful uh we home
school this is our first year
homeschooling
um how did that go we tried it this year
and it was like
a dumpster fire in a
in a horse manure factory it was not
great
how are you how's yours guys you all are
doing well i'm sorry
yeah my girls they are eager learners
they're really curious so it's actually
been fun to
learn with them i can hear you smiling
through the phone
like this this brought you joy huh
yes okay so what ways do you think
you're not connecting with them
um i just feel like a lot of my daily
tasks
they're just that you know i i touch
them all the time but
it when i brush their hair when you know
i'm
you know putting lotion on after a bath
or
those kind of things and i just want to
know that
that they're meaning something yeah
so you uh i want to go back to what i
said earlier you got to let
this guy go this guy being your dad and
i'm calling him this guy on purpose he
he was your he fathered you but he was
not a dad to you
you got to let him go and here's why
you're
doing a great job and there's something
really important about letting your kids
know they matter
and there's something really important
about letting them know
that that they don't run your life too
it's important that they see you work
it's important that you say things like
mommy has to do these projects and i
need you all to go in this room by
yourself away from me for a while
and that way they learn boundaries and
they learn personal responsibility and
they learn to self-soothe
and they learn to play with one another
they learn how to be bored which is a
skill that we have just
robbed our children of and you've got to
learn
and this is going to be hard children
are resilient
you're going to have you are too you're
going to have to learn
how to do things without them in the
room you're going to have to learn to
have
your own joy and your own marriage
and your own fill in the blank without
them without without that sense of
guilt that you're not contributing to
them there's an hour where you weren't
pouring into them does that make sense
oh absolutely
you're gonna have to let yourself you're
gonna have to let tiffany off the hook
there
yeah right yeah yeah i can see that
what kind of support do you have your
husband a good guy
oh he's amazing he is a great father
to them really involved and he is a good
teammate for me uh he he does work
a lot um and we do live in a rather
small rural
community
but he's plugged in there with you but
he's plugged in yes
that's awesome so when you describe
yourself to somebody
do you describe yourself as do you think
of yourself
as a trauma survivor as an abuse
survivor
or do you think of yourself as a really
awesome mom
an awesome wife a great partner to a
great guy
what's the thoughts in your head
um i mean depends on the day i mean i do
believe that i
try my hardest with the tools that i
have i just
don't feel equipped to be the wife and
mom that
i'd really like to be
have you seen a counselor before
no okay so that might be helpful here's
to learn new strategies as your
daughters grow up when they reach
certain ages
when your abuse um that
when you remember it you're gonna have
some different sorts of responsibilities
some different sorts of memories some
different sorts of flashbacks right so
those things happen
it'd be good to check in with somebody
but one of the one of the ugly ugly
things of abuse
is one of the ugly things of growing up
in the growing up in the home of an
addict
one of the ugly things about growing up
not connected to adults
is that you go around feeling like you
are causing everyone else
problems that everyone else is
struggling because you're not holding up
you're into the bargain
and that's what's so exhausting
existentially and personally
about growing up in a world where
there's abuse is you're trying to fix
everybody you're trying to help
everybody else
and you just always feel that hollow
sense that i'm not worthy
and i need you to hear me say you are
not the worst thing that's ever happened
to you
you are not a um
you're you're not that same little girl
that was told you're worthless
and that was abused you're an awesome
awesome mom
i i could hear you on the phone smiling
you have any people i've talked to this
year that were homeschooling that i
could hear them smiling
zero you're the only one
you're the only one your daughters are
so so so so lucky to have you they're so
lucky to have you
your husband's lucky to have you you're
lucky to have one another
and so i want you to go do the hard hard
work i want you to write that letter i
want you to let that guy
go think of him in a in a
small tiny boat like a little sailboat
and i
need you to let him off out to sea the
way he treated you
what he did to you the way he talked to
you the way he
cost your mom her ability to connect
with you
all of that is not your fault and all
that ends
today so you have blessed this show by
calling tiffany
dealing with trauma is hard
and you have done your work you must
have had people pour into you
you must have worked your butt off you
must be surrounded by people who love
you because
you're a shining example of what life
looks like on the other side of trauma
and there is another side an integrated
other side to trauma
here's a couple of things if you are
wrestling with trauma
right it doesn't matter
how long you've haven't dealt with
things how long you
have dealt with things here's a couple
of things you need to know about dealing
with trauma okay
number one you have to acknowledge the
trauma you need to not only know the
facts but also those feelings because
those feelings start to attach
themselves to other things
for instance you're a little girl and
there is somebody sexually abusing you
or physically abusing you as a little
girl
then 25 years later that manifests
itself
and i'm not a good mom i'm not doing
just enough
right you can put in a whole day of
homeschooling your kids
being a great connected wife um running
a side business
going to work as an attorney and then
coming home and taking care of these
business these things or whatever it
happens to be
but that nagging that feeling that i'm
not a good mom that's attached
all the way back to that little girl
who's still trying to figure out why the
one guy
on planet earth who was supposed to
defend and love her decided to hurt her
right so you got to acknowledge not only
the facts but also the feelings
if you don't process what's going on
it's just going to hang on to you
for the rest of your life number two you
gotta find connection
you can only process trauma with
other people right whether it's a group
of nurses huddled up every day before a
shift
or an online resources group or a
group of people who have been through
the same sort of trauma or a
great husband in a counselor instead of
parents whoever it may be
you've got to process trauma in a group
right and you've got to have number
three you've got to
honor and be a good steward of your
heart and your mind and your body
and this is where discipline comes in
there's going to be many many days you
don't want to you don't feel like it
you don't have it in you and you have to
get up and walk you
have to eat right you have to exercise
these are the non-negotiables and folks
i've been there
when i didn't want to get out of bed
when i thought to myself i cannot get
out of bed
and those voices over time i stopped
letting them have a vote
it's not because i'm tough it's not
because i'm jocko
it's just because they didn't get a vote
because i knew that my kids
my wife me my community they deserved
all of me okay and then unplug get off
the electronics connect with people
and then go be brave
bravery's the word right bravery is the
word
i don't know the outcome i don't know
what's gonna happen at the end of this
thing but i'm going to jump with both
feet anyway
that's when you go be brave so
tiffany i'm so it's an honor to have got
to been able to speak with you today
i'm glad that you called you're a great
mom keep going
take care of yourself let that guy go
find a group even in that tiny little
rural town find a counselor if you can
even forgot to make a drive
and stay connected to that awesome
husband of yours good for you all right
let's go to nicole
in tampa florida nicole how are we doing
hi i'm doing well thank you how are you
i'm doing outstanding
so what can i do to help today
so um i dated somebody briefly for about
two months
i got pregnant i told him very early on
when i was about two weeks along
and his response was i had to get an
abortion there was no other option
and i initially considered it
out of fear for about one or two days um
and i had asked him for support and he
just said you know you have my support
and it's to get an abortion so i knew
and so i decided not to get one and i'm
now five months pregnant
and i don't know if i should tell him
now or tell him after the baby is born
i really don't know how to approach this
so
number one i'm i want to applaud you for
following your heart on this one and i
want to applaud you for
doing the hardest thing possible
thank you you can have a girl or a boy
i'm having a girl
have you already thought of a name
um i've thought of a million names very
cool
my wife says you can't name something
somebody until you see it
see them so um
we'll see so i won't you don't have to
disclose the name on the air here
um so here's my thought i think he's got
a right to know
okay i think he needs to know that he's
about to be a dad because he's got some
responsibilities
he's got some financial responsibilities
he's got some or he needs to sign all
that stuff away
through official channels but i do
believe that he has a right to know that
he's got a baby coming into the world
that baby has a right to know that he's
got a mom
and a dad even if they're not together
that baby needs the love of both of
those parents
and so i think there's there's um that's
the right thing to do
is this guy gonna be an idiot and
throw a temper tantrum and be unsafe or
is he going to be all in
what what is your opinion what do you
think he's going to do i really have no
idea
i really thought he was a great guy he's
a great father to his other two children
and this is just not in his life plan
and i think he's just been very selfish
but this was really a surprise to me
that he reacted this way so i don't feel
like
i can read his response to this okay and
i'm obviously very deeply hurt by this
so i don't want
my feelings to get in the mix of this
and
make things matters worse i really want
to have a good co-parenting
relationship so i guess
i'm just really nervous about bringing
this up with him but
y'all are still together are you no no
we pretty much broke up at that point
when he told me to get an abortion
so you all just hooked up for a few
weeks essentially and then you got
pregnant
this year it was about two months of
dating okay okay
yeah i would set up a coffee with him
please for all
for the love of 2021 all 2021 is
depending on you not doing this one
thing okay
okay nicole don't text him this stuff
okay don't email him this stuff have a
meeting with him
in a restaurant in person and obviously
he'll see you and he'll know right away
right i don't well i don't know if
you're showing it five months i'm
looking i don't know
not yet okay we'll let him know that
you're going to be a dad and you decided
to keep the baby
and that just what you told me you've
seen him be a great father
you've seen him be plugged in with his
own kids and you
were hurt by his initial response his
initial
demands if you will um but you're
keeping this baby you want to co-parent
with him you want him in this baby's
life
and that you need him to step up and do
the right thing
because he's having a baby whether he
wants to or not
okay do you feel at peace with that do
you feel
you feel good with that response yeah
you know i typically trust my own
intuition and i was really torn on this
one as to
whether or not i should just lay low and
let him find out i really didn't know
how to approach this one so i really
appreciate you
um taking my question oh you bet i
appreciate you
is this your first is this your first
baby
no i'm a single parent to an
eight-year-old so that was
my initial fear is you know raising
another kid as a single parent and
that's why i initially considered
abortion
even though it was against my beliefs
but i knew i just couldn't make that
decision out of fear
good deal have have you told your
eight-year-old
yeah she's very excited very cool so i'm
gonna give you one hint about your
eight-year-old that a counseling
professor a mentor of mine passed along
and it was magic in my house
okay this comes from dr aretha marbley
who's one of the smartest minds i've
ever
been able to um learn from and she said
start referring to
the unborn baby as
her baby to your eight-year-old sister
okay
okay so or say your baby
is really or your little sister is
really going to love meeting you
your little sister is going to need a
lot of support
i your mommy i'm going to need you to
step up big because your little sister
this baby we're having and what that
language does is kids are
desperate for ownership they're
desperate for participation
and they get months of this apprehension
you can put her hand on your belly and
let her feel it when she starts kicking
all those cool things
but she will begin to take ownership and
you hear a lot about sibling rivalry and
i lost my mom because she had a new baby
and all
in my house i i rolled my eyes and said
all right i'll try it
it was magic it was magic
and my daughter has ended up with the
coolest best big brother you could
imagine
do they fight like morons yes are they
loud and screechy and
yes but i tell you what that that
ownership that my son feels over his
little sister is really something to
behold so it's beautiful
um and so that's that's your that's your
other free advice right you didn't even
call for that one but yeah
dad's got a right to know and dad needs
to have an opportunity to stand up and
do the right thing
and i think by letting him letting him
know
that you believe in him you've seen him
do it once you've seen him do him twice
and that you want to be a great
co-parent with him you want him involved
in this young girl's life
um give him the opportunity to do the
right thing
and if not then there may be legal
obligations here
he's but he's got a financial
responsibility but hopefully bigger than
just the financial responsibility
is he's got the human the integrity
the fathering responsibility being a dad
to this little girl all right let's take
one more call let's go to renee
in el paso texas renee what's going on
hey how you doing john very good is
renee did i say it right
uh that's correct excellent excellent
all right so what's going on how can i
help
uh today i'm calling uh i need help in
navigating the relationship between
myself and my uh 17 year old daughter
okay
so i'll give you a little bit of
background um so i met my wife
back in 2010 uh and uh
she was seven-year-old at the time from
a previous relationship my
wife had uh when where the dad was never
really involved
okay and they were both living with my
mother-in-law and pretty much that's all
my daughter knew so they were pretty
close
my wife and i dated and got married the
following year
and i adopted her you know it wasn't a
a question of of if i was or i wasn't
hey renee can i stop you right there
sure you're a stud dude thank you i just
want to stop
and acknowledge that i'm grateful for
you
that men like you are out there and
willing to not only
fall in love and get married but is
going to take that next step and make
this this seven-year-old this
eight-year-old
a part of a full family kudos to you
brother that's awesome
all right continue all right so i'm in
the military
and uh shortly after we got married in
2011
we received orders to move overseas
and pretty much uh this when we did this
we left my mother-in-law in california
okay during our first year there
we had a baby and during this time
my mother-in-law who had depression for
for a while passed away
due to lung cancer and my daughter
and my mother-in-law were extremely
close they were best friends so it
really took
a toll on her yeah um during this time
obviously you know moving
adjusting to a new sibling she also had
kind of
feelings that she didn't fit in at
school sure
the reason i say this is because she's a
mixed kid
my wife's white i'm mexican and my
daughter is half black
okay so i mean i'm pretty sure you've
dealt with stuff like this you know
she's not gonna be accepted by the white
kids and sometimes uh you know she was
struggling because she wasn't black
enough to be with the black kids from
what my daughter would tell me you know
absolutely and is she was she in a dodd
school overseas
correct okay so we saw
a family therapist for about two and a
half years with not a lot of change
um you know everyone she saw she didn't
really like she didn't really try to
open up to them
you know and i figured that was the case
because you know all this stuff
will put a lot of pressure on her but
essentially from what me and my wife got
it was she kind of got the
the role of me against the world yep
from what we feel and she didn't really
get over it
so kind of uh so we've moved back to or
uh we got stationed in el paso about
four years ago
okay and our relationship has had its
ups and downs you know from really highs
really lows
um my wife and i have been trying to
show her we love her but sometimes it
seems like it's never enough
yeah um so it's kind of like hey uh
if it's something uh that
we agree with her or that's fun with her
she loves it you know we're
we're the best parents in the world but
if we don't agree with her or if there's
other stuff you know taking time
uh away from uh you know not the
spotlight on her but just spending time
with her
she says that you know she's not loved
and she's alone
okay and uh for the past couple of years
we've been trying to
uh prepare her since she got into high
school like hey prepare for adulthood
and you know it's it's been tough to say
the least right
um she is a great kid she gets good
grades uh she's very
very considerate and loves her siblings
so now we just got baby number
number four whoa um yes
uh so baby number four in addition to
her so you've got five
no so she's the number or uh the new
baby's baby number four
okay excellent okay so uh she's just
never been a kid that
takes a lot of initiative and stuff like
that even if it's for her benefit
sure sometimes it's like pulling teeth
but i'm assuming that's uh
likely with all teenagers uh she has
this dream of attending a four-year
state college become a psychologist
stuff like that
but where you know we just started
following dave ramsey a couple years ago
my wife turned me on to it
and and you know we're getting there but
that for her that means that we're not
going to be able to
financially help her a whole lot sure
so with some of this stuff uh each thing
that we've been trying to do
just it's kind of met with the
resistance sure and right now our
relationship it's probably the worst
it's ever
been you know she's kind of gaining a
voice
17 you know she knows she wants to move
out of the house when she's 18
and and go to college it's just one of
those things that
you know just because we love her i i
don't want to lie to her or
send her on the wrong path right so we
don't see eye to eye
very much on a lot of her decisions
and right now i'm pretty uh physically
and mentally drained i don't want to
fight with her but i also don't want to
stop being her parent
and do things that benefit her you know
absolutely i want to focus
instead of building our relationship
obviously
yeah you know it's just one of those
things that right now i just feel like
i can't reason with emotions sometimes
and some of you she has
especially with the cancel type of uh
you know mentality so i think right now
for the past month it's you know she's
been ignoring me stuff like that and
i don't know what to do um man there's a
lot there
so again i don't it's the second time
i'm gonna do this in the same call
i want to commend you for being a dad
who loves his daughter and is trying to
figure it out
and again you're you're the noblest of
the nobleman man i thank you for your
military service i thank you for
um really plugging in and trying to get
at the heart of
what's going on at your daughter here
tell me about her mom
uh so i mean mom she had her when she
was
uh in high school so teenage mom okay um
my wife was kind of hanging around the
the wrong crowd but when she got
pregnant at 16
it kind of changed uh the world you know
for her
and she wanted to be more than what she
was doing
you know she had a dream of being a
nurse
and just kind of turned it around from
there very cool
and what's the relationship like between
her mom
and your daughter it's pretty much the
same
uh because me and my wife are very
tight-knit you know it's kind of creepy
because we're uh we see either add a lot
on a lot of stuff where
you know pretty much type a
personalities like uh just
you know if there's something to get
done let's get it done or or you know
just push ahead and my daughter is
complete opposite okay
so here's a i'm gonna paint you a full
picture and then give you a couple of
strategies here
and then um
then we can go from there and i want to
commit to stay in touch with you over
the next year or two all right
as you weather and navigate this okay
so when when somebody rattles off like
you just did
teen mother father left just never in
the picture
um the cultural challenges of being a
biracial kid
raised by a third race by biracial
couple right overseas on a military base
and then adding in um uh new siblings
one after the other after the other
that's a lot right and you know that
right
but when you put it all together in one
picture
the root question that that 17 year old
baby girl of yours
is continuing to ask and has been asking
since she was old enough to ask
questions
is why did my daddy leave me
and that question cannot be answered
with facts it can only be answered with
community
and connection and so
in steps you a man who has
committed his life to loving this girl
in a noble and extraordinary way
so good for you you have to know that
you are playing a long game here
okay and my guess is
the next couple of years are going to be
rocky and she needs to see boundaries
and she needs to know you cannot ignore
your parents in
our home you can't do that you don't
have permission to do that you're going
to be
a person of character going to talk to
us when we ask you questions
and also going to war with somebody who
is
still struggling isn't helpful either
and so
here's a couple of things that are just
coming to me on top of my head and you
may have some examples i'd love to hear
from you
but what i want to do is set up a
a regularly scheduled engagement with
you and her and she's got to do this
with her mom
quite honestly that's the relationship
that needs healing
um deep down she knows what a stud you
are
okay your daughter knows she's smart
enough to know that you're a good man
that came in and provided her and her
mom a place to live and
a stable home and no matter what she
says right now she's being 17 she's
testing boundaries she's
all over the place and so on and so
forth but she knows you're good
the person she needs to deeply deeply
connect with is mom
and to your knowledge have mom and her
ever gone out and had the conversation
about here's who i was when i was 15 and
16.
here's some decisions i made his mom
ever sat down and talked to her about
her past
and the heartache and how challenging it
was
yes she's sat down with her a couple of
times
throughout the years whenever she wants
to find out more either
just kind of about her her dad her
biological dad okay
um and they've talked it's just it's
kind of tough obviously especially for
for her because i know it's hard for her
yes they have had those conversations
okay so i want to make those types of
conversations
and more types of conversation i want to
make
that sort of communication a regular
practice in your home
and that might be once a week you've got
to go have
lunch or breakfast or dinner or whatever
with just one of us
and you and your wife can alternate and
you can tell your daughter
no electronics and you can sit there in
silence and just stare at me
but i'm gonna come up with a list of
questions to check in on you and see how
you're doing
and this might mean you are asking her
what her three favorite groups music
groups are and you're gonna have to
do you're gonna have to like get a mma
mouthpiece and bite down on it and
listen to those groups
and tell them that you think they're
like these are awful
or i don't understand this song help me
with this and when i'm at what i'm
asking you to do
is to lean into her world a little bit
and what that is going to do is show her
one key trait that she does not get
she's never been able to get because
this meant weakness
and this meant somebody else is going to
hurt her and you're going to teach her
vulnerability
and you're going to teach her not
vulnerability doesn't mean you can run
all over me and vulnerability doesn't
mean you don't have accountability and
vulnerability doesn't mean
that you can just do whatever you want
because you're 17 and i don't want to
make you mad
and it doesn't mean that your 17 year
old is suddenly going to be like oh you
know what i'm just going to
that's not going to happen either but
you're teaching her
a skill you're teaching her a trait that
is
relationship looks like somebody doing
something uncomfortable
even as little as i'll listen to your
music but oh man
or we're gonna read a book together or
we're gonna go
i'm going to watch whatever weird movie
you want me to watch but you get we're
going to go to breakfast and we're going
to talk about it
so these breakfasts are non-negotiable
right
you live in my house this is going to be
part of those and she's 17 so she may be
out in a year
so you don't have a ton of time that's
why i say usually i would say once a
month but
you're running out of time and so i
would say every week and
offline i would ask you and your wife to
commit
to listening more at these
lunches at these breakfasts and talking
less giving less advice
and leaning in more get to know your
daughter
and i know that you already know i know
you've had some hard conversations
before but i want you to
invest in letting her voice be heard
because here's what she's going to do
she's going to practice letting her
voice be heard
and right now it feels like emotion it
feels like jumbled up mess inside that
17 year old head
and she's dealing with all of this stuff
starting with my dad didn't even care
enough about me to stick around he
didn't care enough to meet me
and i'm not african-american enough over
here i'm
not white enough over here well no i
don't don't even speak the language
because i'm overseas
or i'm just hanging a bunch of military
brat kids and now i'm back and i got
three kids in the house what in the
world i can't wait to just get out of
here
right most of the time when a 17 year
old says i just want to get
just get out of here that's not they
don't mean that
what they're saying is i just want to
belong
i want to matter i want to have a role
in this home
and right now all this pain all of this
confusion is too much for my 17 year old
mind
i just want to run i just want to run i
just want to get out of here
and that's where you showing
vulnerability
leaning into that baby girl saying this
is what it looks like it looks like
paying for a meal
everybody drops their shoulders there's
no mad there's no frustrated there's
all right what's your three favorite
groups we're getting into this
tell me some things about you that i
don't know what's the funniest thing
that happened hey i thought of three
hilarious things that happened when i
was a kid that i've never even shared
with you
that looks like your wife being really
really vulnerable
and telling her what her relationship
with her mom and dad were like
and how she's trying so hard to be a
different kind of mom and what we're
looking for is connection points
out of vulnerability
that's a lot and here's the thing i said
earlier and i kind of blew over it you
are playing a long game now
17 18 if she packs up and moves out at
18
and she runs she says i'm out of here
she'll be back continue to love her
continue to write letters to her so she
can hold those letters and read them and
see them and feel them
and she'll keep them
continue to hold your boundaries firm
but continue to let that girl know that
she's loved
ah renee i want you to have that initial
conversation and i want you to have that
first
breakfast that first lunch and then i
want you to call me back because i want
to know how it went
and it may dude it may be a disaster it
may
be awful but it may be a tiny baby step
in the right direction all right so
thanks brother thanks for calling as we
wrap up today the song of the day
man this is a legend it's a classic
that's one of the greatest songs ever
written it's the greatest song ever
written
it's from it's an album almost as
creatively titled as the dr john de loni
show
it's titled two from the 1969
album two by the one and only led
zeppelin
the song it's awesome but i just don't
even know what it means
it's called what is and what should
never be
and it robert plant sings like this
and if i say to you tomorrow take my
hand child come with me
it's to a castle i will take you where
what's to be
they say will be catch the wind see us
spin
sail away and leave today way up high in
the sky but the wind won't below
you really shouldn't go it only goes to
show that you will be mine by taking our
time
see i don't know what this means but
it's awesome and if you say to me
tomorrow
oh what fun it will be it would be
then what's to stop us pretty baby but
what is and what should never be
[Music]
what has been is the dr john delonay
show thank you so much i'll see you soon
you